Announcer: From the nation's capital!
The American Enterprise Institute for Public Policy Research presents
Public Policy Forums.
A series of programs featuring the nation's top authorities presenting their differing views
on the vital issues which confront us.
Today's topic arm sales, a useful foreign
policy tool?
John Charles Daly: An examination of arms sales
or arms transfers if you will as a tool of
foreign policy must inevitably recognize the
potential of such sales to affect the economic,
military, psychological as well as the diplomatic
posture of the recipients.
More in each of these areas the recipient's
posture plays a part large or small but always
important in the grand design of US policy
to protect crucial American interests and
those of our allies in Western Europe, the
Middle East, Africa, Asia and South America.
Our discussion of arms sales to be sure is
concerned solely with conventional arms, not
atomic weapons but a vital factor is the extraordinary
sophistication which has developed in conventional
arms in this electronic era and the potential
hazards to our own overall security if these
sophisticated elements are in the hands of
nations whose borders lie in the volatile
areas of confrontation between the interests
of the United States and her allies and the
Soviet Union.
In mid-1981 the Reagan administration announced
its arms transfer policy emphasizing that
the "basic thrust is to recognize that arms
transfers properly considered and employed
represent an indispensable instrument of American
policy that both complements and supplements
the role of our own military forces".
This is a marked change of direction from
Carter administration policy emphasizing restraint
and primary consideration of a recipient's
human rights policies in approving arms sales.
But to examine the question mark on our arms
sales issue we have a highly expert panel.
To my far right Lieutenant General Brent Scowcroft,
a West Point graduate who holds a doctorate
in international relations from Columbia University,
served with the Joint Chiefs of Staff and
after retiring from the service was assistant
to President Ford for national security affairs.
To my immediate right, Representative William
L. Dickinson, a Republican from Alabama and
ranking minority member of the House Armed
Services Committee and Subcommittee on Research
and Development.
To my immediate left, Senator Joseph R. Biden
of Delaware, member of the Senate Foreign
Relations Committee.
Senator Biden served as chairman of the US
Senate Delegations on SOK2 in Moscow and to
the North Atlantic Assembly in Ottawa in 1979.
To my far left, Representative Less Aspin,
six term Democrat from Wisconsin with a doctorate
in economics from MIT.
Doctor Aspin earlier served as an economist
with the Pentagon and now is a member of the
Armed Services and Budget Committees of the
House.
Well, to begin gentlemen I would pose the
same question to each of you in turn.
To what extent should an arms transfer or
sales program play a role in our foreign policy?
Senator Biden.
Senator Biden: Well, it seems to me that we
have an expression, those of us who practiced
law before coming to the Congress that hard
cases make bad law.
And I think it's very difficult to make sweeping
statements and generalities about arms control
policy but to the extent that one must be
made it seems to me that the US should have
a restrained...be both restrained and prudent
in making arms transfers and arms sales while
at the same time recognizing that in particular
circumstances they can be very vital and important
to US interests.
There are instances where arms transfers are
in fact absolutely essential for US interests
and others where we have made bad or incorrect
judgments about the stability of the nations
to whom we were transferring the arms and
failed in other instances to factor in the
arms transfer as part of the overall foreign
policy determination for a region or a country.
So it's sort of a mixed bag.
I think it's neither indispensable as this
administration says nor should it have been
an exceptional tool in our foreign policy
as the last administration indicated.
John Charles Daly: Representative Dickinson.
Representative Dickinson: I agree in the main...with
what the senator said.
Whether we like it or not it is an instrument
of foreign policy and you cannot escape it.
That being so, the best thing we could do
and what we should do is to use it as Senator
Biden said in a very prudent manner.
But whether we are talking about our friends
and allies or potential adversaries we are
going to have to influence our foreign policy
with the use of weapon sales just as the Soviets
do, just as the French do and I don't advocate
an arms race but to say that it is not an
instrument of it is to ignore the obvious.
John Charles Daly: Representative Aspin?
Representative Aspin: I agree.
I think that there's no question that it is
an instrument whether we like it or not.
There it is.
What makes it so difficult is that there is
an ethical and a moral dimension to arms sales
as well as a national security dimension.
It's not unlike human rights in that way.
It's a complicated issue where you've got
ethics and morality competing with national
security considerations which means I think
two things.
Number one, it's very difficult to take an
extreme position either totally for arms sales
or totally against and secondly, it's very,
very difficult to be totally consistent.
You may find two similar cases.
In one case you wanna sell arms, in other
case you're not.
All in all, it's a very difficult subject
to deal with.
John Charles Daly: General Scowcroft.
General Scowcroft: I think it's a rather important
as an instrument of US foreign policy.
After all there are relatively few such instruments
that we have.
We have diplomatic policy, economic policy,
economic aid and arms transfers if you will.
Arms transfers are unique in the sense that
whether we like it or not the world in which
we live is one in which power is a primal
element.
And where that is a case insecurity is also
an important element.
And arms sales in addition to US military
policy itself, the US military guarantees
and so on serves an indispensable role in
lessening the kind of insecurity that the
world in which we live in produces.
John Charles Daly: Right.
We're examining a change in direction in arms
transfer policy.
President Carter launched a restraint policy,
a unilateral effort to reduce arms transfers
to the Third World with a multibillion dollar
ceiling but a set of guidelines hopefully
setting a good example to other arms suppliers
and he also had a multilateral effort launched
in discussions with European nations and formal
negotiations with the Soviet Union.
Even earlier the Congress had restricted arms
transfers and assistance personnel by numbers,
by control of credit, by the nature of the
recipient regimes, etc.
But both of these efforts it seems bore little
fruit.
What went wrong?
General Scowcroft, would you start?
General Scowcroft: Well, I think they bore
little fruit because I think they were well
meaning but fundamentally misguided and that
is they operated on the premise, the simple
and in many ways comforting premise that arms
create wars and that therefore it's intrinsically
an evil and should be engaged in only when
our overriding national interests are involved.
And it seems to me that fundamentally misses
the point.
Long before there were complicated weapon
systems, long before there was gunpowder there
was war.
Conflict is older than recorded history and
it's deeply rooted in the nature of man.
And it seems to me that arms and arms races
really represent the thermometer, not the
disease and that we're not likely to cure
the disease by breaking the thermometer.
Now I think certainly a lot of our friends
use arms or want arms for purposes we do not
consider overriding.
Nevertheless, are we really to set ourselves
up as the judge of the fundamental national
interests of our friends?
And it seems to me that the answer to that
question is fundamentally what was wrong with
the policy of the previous administration.
Senator Biden: If I may, I think I disagree
with the general.
At least to some degree.
I would suggest that the real issue is not
whether or not nations in effect would fight
anyway and I think the general's correct.
I mean, whether or not they had the SAM missiles
provided by the Soviet Union or whether or
not they had sophisticated airplanes supplied
by the United States or France...if they didn't
have those they'd use slingshots or rocks
or bow and arrows or whatever.
But I do think US national interest is impacted
upon significantly depending on the degree
to which...of sophistication of the weaponry.
For example, it is much less likely that a
conflict that is limited to obsolete tanks
and old M1 riffles or their counterparts or
Remington rifles is going to embroil a whole
region of the world and in fact bring the
United States into a confrontation it would
otherwise like to avoid thereby either bringing
in the Soviets, or the Soviets first making
it an east-west confrontation.
I think that the extent to which that occurs
at least in some part depends upon the degree
of sophistication of the weapons.
The reason why the Congress got in the business
of saying that we wanna have at least a say
in that because it is a component of foreign
policy was because it went from $1.7 billion
to somewhere in the order of $16 billion in
a matter of 4 years.
And it looked as though to some of us that
was becoming almost the sole criteria for
determining what reach we would have abroad.
And I am much more Machiavellian I guess than
my friend, the general.
And in fact I do think if we are transferring
arms we should first and foremost conclude
whether or not it impacts favorably on our
national interest.
If it does and yet it does not impact on their
interest, I would vote to send the arms.
If it does not yet it does favorably impact
on them I would be inclined not to send the
arms.
That's an oversimplification.
And last point in the regard to transfers,
there are two elements of the transfers.
We compete not only with our Soviet friends...they
are our enemy.
They are in fact engaged in confrontation
in various levels and stages throughout the
world and we are engaged with them but we
are also engaged with our allies.
And it seems to me that one of the things
we have missed and one of the things as chairing
the European committee for some years now
in the Senate is that we are somewhat timid
about speaking to our allies firmly about
what we are...what the quid pro quo for them
doing such and such is.
And so we tend to say...we say we are as helpless
in dealing with French sales which may be
true, British sales or any other ally as we
are with Soviet sales to Third World countries
and I think we should at some point at least
in the Congress address whether or not we
are...have been tough enough where we can
be tough.
Representative Aspin: Let me agree with some
of what General Scowcroft said and some of
what Senator Biden said.
I think that it's true that arms do not create
the conflict.
The conflict was there before the arms, that
the conflict will go on whether we provide
the arms or not, that...who are we to judge
their national security interests.
They have to look at their own national security
interests.
But we...it's our decision as to whether we
are to sell them a particular weapon or weapon
system.
And I think that given the limited leverage
implied by your statement which I agree with
that we have limited leverage even if we provide
them the arms that we had better make pretty
sure that their national security interests
at least in the use of that weapon is consistent
with ours.
John Charles Daly: Congressman Dickinson?
Representative Dickinson: Well, I don't know
that I can add much to this particular point
except to underscore the fact that we do sell
arms should be to promote our national interests,
not to help that country necessarily.
If by helping that country we promote our
interests, yes.
But then getting back to Les's point, I don't
know that we can properly put ourselves in
the role of judge and say, "Well, we don't
believe that this is in your national interest
so country of Chile, we won't sell you a sophisticated
airplane."
So they go and buy a Mirage from France.
Or we say to South Africa, "We don't like
your internal politics.
We need you strategically, we need your minerals
but we won't sell you a submarine."
So what do they do?
They go to France and buy submarines.
We haven't denied anything except we put a
strain on the relationship and maybe to the
point of breach at some time.
But you see, when you talk about weapon sales
that's just a part of it.
And there is a pending deal now with Saudi
Arabia for about $8.5 billion.
Well, if you break that down only about $2
billion, $2 billion to $3 billion is actually
for weapons.
The rest of it is going into hospitals, it
goes into the infrastructure, it goes to train
people.
Their people come over here, we go over there.
There's a cultural exchange.
And so there's a very large ripple effect
than...I just picked Saudi because they have
the largest pending sale now.
But in countries around the world all of these
ripple effects are very important to us.
And so we have to look at what is our national
interest and it'd be very difficult...it is
very difficult to say, "Well, we won't sell
it to you."
And then force them to go someplace else.
John Charles Daly: General, you want...
General Scowcroft: Yep.
Well, I think it goes without saying, senator,
that our national interest is what we're concerned
about, not the national interest of the recipient.
But presumably our national interest is involved
in making them feel more secure for some purpose
that we have in mind and it's that that I
meant when we say, "You don't really need
those things.
We wanna help you.
We're your friend but you don't really need
those weapons."
And it's that that I think gets over to the
point Congressman Dickinson had.
Senator Biden: Two brief points with regard
to that.
First of all, it seems to me that a point
that Congressman Dickinson just made...take
South Africa for an example.
The implication is because South Africa went
to an ally, France, or will go to an ally,
France, to get the same thing we wouldn't
sell them that somehow that doesn't benefit
us particularly.
Let me suggest that that may be of immense
benefit to us.
Let's assume that one of the downsides I think
we'll all agree, potential downside...it doesn't
always occur but one of the downsides when
it occurs of an arms transfer to another country
may very well be that we feel we have to because
of security reasons give aid, military aid
but we know we're gonna suffer propaganda
price for having done so.
So I would suggest that in a sophisticated
arms transfer policy...and I realize I'm coming
off as the young prince here, Machiavelli,
but I would suggest that sometimes it makes
sense for us to forego the downside which
is the propaganda loss as a consequence of
a transfer to what we would acknowledge as
a regime that doesn't particularly have values
compatible with what we view ours to be and
yet accomplish the same goal by having an
ally move and fill that vacuum.
Second point is that with regard to the question
of insecurities of foreign countries I think
one of the problems that we sometimes face,
democratic and republic administrations has
been that we fuel the insecurities of insecure
leaders.
We give them a false sense of security by
the transfer of arms.
I can think of no greater case in point than
Iran.
I can think of no instance in recent history.
Quite frankly the history of the United States
of America in transfer of arms where we in
fact kidded ourselves and allowed the shah
to kid himself.
Here we had close to $30 billion worth of
the most sophisticated arms in the world and
not a shot was fired.
Not a single shot that I'm aware of.
He was marched out of the country.
His successor was marched out of the country
and all those weapons are either lying dormant
and/or have become...they have been accessed
by the KGB and the Soviet Union and/or are
being prepared to be used in a way if they
ever get their act together that may be by
inimicable to our interests.
We're now told with regard to Saudi Arabia
the reason why we should sell them certain
weapons including AWACS is because there's
a runway in Iran.
And Iran has those F and...well, I won't go
through all the weaponry but Iran has those
weapons that can take off, be across the Gulf
in a matter of minutes and now we have to
supply a nation with sophisticated weaponry
to shoot down the sophisticated weaponry we
gave an insecure leader who we should've known
we were just feeding his insecurity if we
had been willing to look beyond our own intelligence
apparatus, training of their intelligence
apparatus through whom we got the advice.
That's an overstatement I'm afraid but that's
a tendency of senators, I guess.
John Charles Daly: It's very interesting.
General, would you like to take on...
General Scowcroft: Yes.
I think it's a substantial overstatement and
it seems to me that recent events in Iran,
if they've shown anything, it's that the situation
with the shah is far more complicated than
it appeared at the time.
In 1971 when the British pulled out of the
Gulf we had 3 ways to go.
We could try to keep them there and subsidize
them, we could replace them with our own forces
or we could try to create a bastion of strength
there.
We chose the third.
Man: A correct choice in my opinion.
General Scowcroft: Now I suggest that it was
highly successful and that while the shah
was there the Gulf was stable.
There wasn't a war between Iran and Iraq.
It didn't cost us anything.
As a matter of fact, economically it benefited
us.
I think it's a moot point how much it did
or did not have to do with the shah's fall
but afterwards what have we had to replace
the shah with?
Two carrier task forces, an RDF that we're
trying to fund, billions of dollars that is
gonna cost the United States to replace what
we had in the shah.
Senator Biden: I don't disagree that we should...
John Charles Daly: May I just throw that RDF being
a rapid deployment force.
What other hazards of having sophisticated
weaponry of the kind that we did transfer
to the shah...
Senator Biden: May I make...and I think the
fundamental question is...was all of that
weapons that we sold to the shah necessary
to play the role that General Scowcroft is
saying that we wanted the shah to play.
I think that the point is correct that we
were looking for a substitute for the Brits,
we were looking for somebody to provide some
stability in the area but does that mean F14s,
DD-963 destroyers...I mean, does the whole
baggage have to come with that?
My answer to that would be no.
I mean, there's a role to play.
There was an...an arms sales would've been
a part of it.
But all of these extremely sophisticated weapons
I think...
You could argue that it made his military
force less effective than it might've been.
It stretched their technology, their technical
people very, very thin.
We never know because of course the shah's
army and air force and navy was never put
to the test.
It crumbled from within rather than was defeated
from...it never...so we never know.
But I think that you don't have to sell them
everything to follow the policy that you're
advocating there.
General Scowcroft: I wouldn't disagree with
that and I think reasonable people can disagree
over weapon system by weapon system.
John Charles Daly: When Representative Dickinson
raised very briefly an issue that became a
cause célèbre of the Saudi Arabian
purchase which included the AWACS.
So this is an area in which we are caught
between the nether and the near millstone.
It's almost impossible to come out of it without
making somebody upset at us.
Is this an area that is so common and constant
in this field that we really should shrink
from the whole arms transfer business as much
as possible because of the problems they can
raise?
Senator Biden: I think there's one thing that's
part of this is that there's maybe an asymmetry
here that you don't get much from selling
it but you might get a lot...get hurt a lot
if you announce that you're gonna...thinking
about selling it and then deny the sale.
General Scowcroft: I think there's a lot of
truth in there.
Senator Biden: And I think that that's part
of the arms sale problem is this asymmetry
that it...that by selling it we may get a
little bit of leverage, we may get some goodwill,
we may gain a little bit but the downside
if you don't sell it turns out to be enormous
with these countries.
I mean, they take it as a personal affront
and a rejection and I think that's what gets
us into trouble is that we make these deliberations
in public as we...as you do but if the decision
turns out negative it can have severe consequences.
Representative Aspin: I don't disagree with
that but I would like to add one point about
Saudi Arabia.
I think Saudi Arabia falls into the category
that I arbitrarily said I thought there were
two categories.
One where if we don't supply, an ally will
supply.
And the other one is if we don't supply, the
Russians are coming and they're gonna move
in and they're gonna become the supplier and
we're gonna have a reverse Ethiopia or Somalia
or Egypt.
They're all the places we can know where we've
each been suppliers and one moves out and
one moves in.
In the case of Saudi Arabia, I think that
there is no more complicated part of the world
than the Middle East.
Not many I think would disagree with that.
And we have what appear to be, appear I emphasize,
conflicting foreign policy goals and the transfers
of this...of sophisticated weaponry to either
Israel or to any Arab state, in this case
the Saudis, can further complicate that so
that we started off I thought or we...I think
we should start off with saying, "Is our arms
transfers a part of foreign policy?"
And I think the problem we have in the Middle
East is the determination of our foreign policy.
Now foreign policy can be complicated by an
arms transfer.
And let me just give you one case in point
where I didn't think that sale should go forward.
Forget all the questions about whether or
not Israel was more or less secure, whether...what
it does, whether it'll work, how much of an
umbrella it presents, etc.
It seems to me that the Saudis have been very
deft at seeing to it that they give little
more than lip service to involvement in any
Mid East war up to now.
They've essentially said to their Arab friends
when they said, "Jump on with us."
They've said, "But we'll send money.
We wish you luck.
We'll pray at the mosque for you."
And so on.
But now it seems to me because the interest
we're looking to protect there is oil to the
western world and Japan...I mean, I think
we can be as fairly naked.
We're in a situation where I think the sale
of this sophisticated weaponry makes Saudi
Arabia a valuable ally to the rest of the
Arab world if there is confrontation.
And failure to join the cause and engage that
weaponry if confrontation occurs I think will
result in what is the most likely thing to
occur and that is internal espionage and sabotage,
those wells being blown up by some of the
two million Palestinians who run them now
anyway and the end result will be the foreign
policy initiative we were setting out to protect,
that is free access to that oil, may very
well be hindered instead of helped by the
transfer.
John Charles Daly: General Scowcroft?
General Scowcroft: I wonder if that's really
the case.
In the first place the Saudis have given token
help before.
It seems to me in the '67 war they sent a
brigade or a battalion.
I'm not sure it ever got there.
Representative Aspin: Yeah.
It's only been token.
That's the point.
General Scowcroft: That's right.
They have done things.
And I'm not sure that that would not be the
case in any future...as a matter of fact I'd
say the reverse would be true that it would
be involved mostly because the Israelis might
feel it was vital to take out that AWACS in
case a war started.
I think that's, you know, that's a possibility.
Senator Biden: General, as a military planner
wouldn't you assume that if you were an Israeli
planner?
Wouldn't you assume if there's a war that
those F15s are not gonna sit on a runway and
those AWACS are not gonna be just focused
on the east and that you better hit first.
I mean, you're a general.
I mean, wouldn't you sit there and say, "That's
the logical thing to do."
General Scowcroft: I would certainly make
plans for it but the Israelis have not hit
all the Arab targets that they had the capability
of hitting in previous wars.
Senator Biden: But none have had as...the
ones they haven't hit have not had the potential
capability to wreak havoc on them, that the
weaponry we are now selling will and does.
That's the only point I'm...
Representative Aspin: That's true.
But, you know, but this may be a case which
in a sensory future argument about the sophistication
being an evil, in fact it may be a benefit
here because the equipment is so sophisticated.
And that may be the case in a number of cases,
that it cannot usefully be operated without
American help which gives us additional leverage
to ensure, unlike M1 rifles and grenades and
so on that they don't need any help for, there's
this additional leverage in the way that those
weapons will be used.
Representative Dickinson: It seems to me that
we completely ignore and look aside at the
real issue but if we talk about AWACS and
is...how is it in our best interest and what
action should we take?
We are almost governed, it's too strong a
word, but we...the Israeli government and
the supporters of Israel have an inordinate
impact on our Congress and that's really what...we're
not...the president has said it's in the interest
of the United States, Secretary Haig has said
it's in the interest.
If you look to see the history of Saudi in
the past few years and the friendship they
have offered us...and I'm talking about OPEC
now, OPEC was just trying to raise their price
from $32 to $36 a barrel.
It was the Saudis that kept them from doing
that.
They have done that on at least three different
occasions.
It was the Saudis that kept the Jordanians
and others that wanted OPEC to go off the
dollar standard onto another monetary exchange.
So there have been any number of instances
where we've been the beneficiary of the friendship
of the Saudis.
And to...for us to say that it's not in our
interest to continue the friendship and to
give them a defensive capability and that's
what we're talking about here and not the
F15s but in AWACS I think it would be particularly
shortsighted and I would certainly support
it.
Representative Aspin: You can't let it go
by.
I think that it's important that...to...when
you look at what the Saudis have done with
oil prices, what they've done in the economic
sphere it's very clear that they have not
done anything that is not out of line with
their own self-interest.
There's a...
Representative Dickinson: Wait for just a
moment.
What about keeping the prices down?
You think that was...
Representative Aspin: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
Representative Dickinson: But all of the other
nations wanted to raise it in OPEC.
Representative Aspin: That's right.
But they perceived it in their own self-interest
to keep the oil prices down because if the
prices go up the substitution for oil in the
industrial west becomes quicker, their resources
of oil in their...in the ground becomes obsolete
quicker.
But I don't think you can look at anything
in the oil and the economic sphere and make
a case that Saudi Arabia is doing us any favors.
I mean, they may be doing us some favors as
a byproduct of doing themselves some favors.
What would be really impressive to me would
be if they would throw their weight in behind
the Camp David Accords.
Now that would be impressive.
And in that case that might change my view
about things like the sale of the F15s and
the AWACS.
General Scowcroft: And if I could just add
one point.
It seems to me we have another interest in
the AWACS in Saudi Arabia aside from what
you've discussed and that is a US national
interest to protect our own forces over there,
you know.
We used to have long-range radar in Iran that
could monitor the Soviet Union and any Soviet
attack.
Our battle fleets there are potentially very
vulnerable.
Man: That's right.
General Scowcroft: To Soviet air attack and
it seems to me that the AWACS serves a very
important role and is right now in giving
us early warning of a possible Soviet attack.
Senator Biden: But general you know better
than I do.
I just spent two days out at our...a day out
at Tinker Air Force Base and spent all kinds
of time in the Intelligence Committee.
The AWACS flown within the boundaries of Saudi
Arabia does not give us any warning that has
anything comparable to that which in fact
existed in Iran.
We have a very limited ability as broad as
it is to be able to detect whether or not
there is a Soviet move and it is really...it's
not even remotely comparable to the Iranian position.
General Scowcroft: Absolutely.
But it is a great deal better than the self-protection
of the carrier.
Senator Biden: Right.
And we have it now.
We have four AWACS there.
They are flying now.
They're American cruised.
They're controlled by America.
And...
General Scowcroft: And they're there at Saudi's
sufferance.
Senator Biden: And Saudi needs them as much
as we do.
Yeah.
John Charles Daly: Well, I think we've gone into
the...I'd like to come back to the fact that
since '72 the Congress has with some assertiveness
moved to try to reduce this issue of arms
transfers.
And I wonder if the efforts of past administrations
and the Congress have not produced a labyrinth
and maze of administrative processes.
Some elements of this program could go through
state, the Defense Departments, the Joint
Chiefs of Staff, the individual services,
the Treasury Department, the Agency of International
Development, the Central Intelligence Agency,
the Office of Management and Budget and we
constructed a system which is just incapable
of flexible response to volatile and ever-changing
worlds.
Congress bill.
A lot of these...and initially what...you...this...you're...you
were in the Congress actually through all
this from '72 to '77 when all that legislation
was going through.
It doesn't work.
I think we all seem to agree that nothing's
worked.
Representative Aspin: It doesn't work in the
sense that arms sales have continued to increase.
What we have done is as you say set up a rather
elaborate procedure in which the Congress
must approve and you have got various players
in the field.
But once you set up a procedure like that
it's hard to be sure that the thing wouldn't
have...would've gone exactly the same without
that procedure.
Yes, Congress has never voted down an arms
sales that has been proposed.
Has an administration ever been dissuaded
from proposing an arms sale because of this
procedure and the fear that Congress might
turn it down?
You know, I think it's very hard to prove
conclusively that this has been a total failure.
Senator Biden: Could I suggest something,
Les, that I...it seems to me that there are
two reasons for the labyrinth, as you refer
to it, that the Congress set up.
One has been I think noticeably and unsuccessful
and one has been very successful.
The first reason was that we hoped, everyone
hoped I think that...who has participated
in it that it would in fact cut down in terms
of the gross quantity of weaponry and dollars
represented in that weaponry that was transferred.
To that extent on a chart that you would draw
and the dollars, sort of weapon value transferred
it hasn't been very successful.
But a second and I believe more important
reason why and I was there from '72 on when
we were doing this also in the Senate was
the foreign policy component of it because
at the outset of this program we all said,
the one thing we all agree on, it is a tool
of foreign policy.
And what happened was we had presidents, Democrats
and Republicans over the previous 15 to...probably
over our history who were in fact treating
what was viewed as an economic decision independent
of the foreign policy consideration that the
Congress said we now wanna be part of.
And to that extent I think it's successful
and has been successful in the...you may argue
Congress wasn't right but it's been successful
and accomplished what Congress set out to
do and that is be a part of the game.
John Charles Daly: General Scowcroft?
General Scowcroft: I think Congress ought
to be involved in these kinds of decisions.
They are fundamentally foreign policy decisions.
I think that Congress really, and this is
very difficult to do, ought to be involved
at the policy stage.
The problem I have with the present procedures
is it's too late when you all get it.
And you cannot reject a proposal of an administration
without doing grievous foreign policy harm
at that point.
Senator Biden: I couldn't agree with you more.
General Scowcroft: That's the problem.
John Charles Daly: I think we've covered a lot of
ground and perhaps raised a good number of
questions among our friends in the audience.
So it's time for the question and answer session.
May I have the first question please?
Harry: I'm Harry Frack from the Olen Corporation.
I noticed all kinds of concerns and effects
of arms transfers but did not find anyone
saying anything about the domestic effects
both economic and in our military preparedness.
About 50% of our companies have been manufacturing
goods for foreign sales which is about the
only thing that's kept our own industry alive
in the defense products area.
John Charles Daly: All right.
Who'd like to start there?
Representative Dickinson: Well, I'll take
it,
to start with.
And you're exactly correct.
Our arms sales has a very wide impact economically
in this country.
As a matter of fact, I was reading some...I
don't know how authoritative it is but some
50,000 families are dependent on sales to
Saudi Arabia alone in this proposed package.
I don't know who put out that propaganda but
it is very, very wide.
And I was just in a defense plant on the West
Coast last week and they were making armored
personnel vehicles and they don't have any
sales to this country now.
They are going to Spain, they go into Israel,
they're going to any number of other countries
but that's what's keeping them going as you
said.
So it is a very broad...if we lost all our
foreign military sales right now the unemployment
rate would go up substantially in this country.
John Charles Daly: General Scowcroft?
General Scowcroft: Well, I don't think there's
any question that it is helpful to American
industry and also to our own armed forces.
It cuts substantially the unit cost of some
of our equipment.
But I'll be something of an iconoclast, I
do not think that our arms sale policy ought
to be dictated by our domestic economic needs.
I think that'll be dictated by our national
interest and solely on that basis.
Senator Biden: Also one other point, a minor
point in this thing and that is that yes,
there are cases where we have sold arms abroad
where there was no demand in the American
armed forces for that equipment and so it
did keep people at work.
There are also cases and probably more now
if we're into a buildup phase in the US military
where you've got competing claims where the
US military also wants the equipment and the
arms sales are competing and you get the question
who gets it first.
Representative Dickinson: Like the F16.
Senator Biden: Yeah, yeah.
I can think of a few.
So it cuts both ways in that regard now.
General Scowcroft: That's true.
Senator Biden: I would like to add one point,
one additional point and I think the gentleman's...the
questioner's point is well taken.
It does positively impact upon our balance
of trade situation.
But it is one of the potential upsides to
arms sales.
But to reiterate General Scowcroft's point
if in fact we have a circumstance where it
becomes the motivating force behind the sale,
not only have we sometimes not had in production
military equipment that our military no longer
needed, what we've tended to do is our arms
merchants have decided to go sell what was
also not needed by the third country, that
particular weapon system.
That has occurred too.
So it's a double edged sword.
General Scowcroft: Yeah, yeah.
John Charles Daly: All right.
Next question please.
Bill: Yes, my name is Bill Wickersham with
the World Federalist Association and I would
direct this to Congressman Aspin.
Most of the panels indicated that they think
the United States should act in its own self-interest
which probably very few people would disagree.
The question is if 159 or so other nations
around the world act in the same way and if
in fact the weaponry becomes more sophisticated
and it becomes dispersed throughout the world
and if in fact as several studies including
some United States government studies suggest
there will be a nuclear capability within
some 29 or 30 nations by let's say year 2000
for sure, how do we contain this so it's not
combustible and we...the whole thing explodes.
Representative Aspin: That is a very good
question.
I think that the phenomenon that you're talking
about is a very serious one and a very real
one.
If you look at the amount of money spent on
arms in the world and just plot that over
a number of years, it's really reaching staggering
proportions.
I am not sure that you can stem that tide
with an arms sales policy alone.
If you had an across the board policy which
I think is unwise to take an extreme position
of not selling anything to anybody no matter
what I think you would be making a not terribly
significant dent on that race.
I think those...the factors that go into arms
races are factors that have to do with...in
national states, there are rivalries with
their neighbors, competing ideologies, competing
religions, all of these things and the impact
of arms sales on that is a factor but a relatively
minor one which...and I think that the problem
is that people tend to look at arms sales
as a good tool to stem that big race.
And my problem is I don't think it will work.
And you're putting an awful lot of weight
on a very think reed to try and accomplish
it through arms sales.
Through eliminating arms sales.
Sorry.
General Scowcroft: If I could just give one
example.
There's one case where we really tried to
do this and that was Latin America in the
1960s.
The Alliance for progress.
We made a policy decision that we were not
gonna sell any arm...any sophisticated arms.
We were not gonna upgrade any of the equipment
that Latin American countries had.
It was a relatively stable period in Latin
America.
The competition between and among the countries
was at a low level.
Most of their equipment, especially their
airplanes, tanks and so on were obsolete.
We stuck to that during almost all of the
'60s.
The result was that they bought arms from
the British, bought arms from the French and
they bought arms from the Russians.
And now maybe in an ideal world we could get
together with our allies and even with the
Russians which the Carter administration tried
to put an end to that sort of thing.
But as a practical matter we don't have very
much leverage.
Senator Biden: May I...Mister Wickersham,
you...implicit in your statement at least
as I heard it was that there's an inconsistency
between a transfer of an arms...or between...potentially
between US self-interest and world harmony.
And I would suggest that if that is part of
your...implicit in your statement that that
is not correct.
I think we're at a stage where one of my colleagues,
southern colleagues in the Senate says, "It's
wonderful when conscience and convenience
cross paths."
And I think in arms control policy we have
the opportunity to have both conscience and
convenience cross paths.
For example, you mentioned nuclear capability.
That is the overwhelming concern for the entire
world it seems to me.
And there are instances where arms transfer
can diminish the prospect of the feeling of
urgency develop...to develop and/or steal,
and/or whatever a nuclear capability and conversely
there are cases which I believe is a situation
potentially in Pakistan where massive arms
transfers can propel the competing countries
in the region to move toward the...a greater
reliance on nuclear.
So it can work to the benefit on occasion
and...but that's what I meant by I think we
should do it case by case.
John Charles Daly: Next question please.
Richard: My name is Richard Daryl.
I'm currently an international affairs fellow
with the Council on Foreign Relations in New
York.
I actually have two questions.
They're interrelated.
The first is if memory serves correct the
biggest market, the biggest business market
that the United States has in the world for
its arms sales policies is in fact our allied
market, and principally our NATO allied market.
That's where most of the sales go on.
Yet on the other hand as I understand it NATO
has various policies itself to which we subscribe.
Policies like rationalization, standardization,
interoperability.
One implication of which is that the allies
should be able to sell us more.
They have learned the domestic effects and
the business benefits of arms sales themselves
in the inter-allied arena and they like to
oftentimes get in on the act.
That creates however a certain tension between
a US policy which is promoting sales to the
alliance and an allied policy which wants
reciprocity.
And my first question then is how do we resolve
this tension and is there room, excuse me,
for a new policy in this general area?
My second question arises from something I
think Senator Biden said earlier and that
was a suggestion that sometimes allied arms
sales abroad are not necessarily detrimental
to us and they might sometimes be encouraged.
I wondered when you made that remark whether
or not this ally...in general allied sales
abroad don't serve as a kind of safety valve
in some ways for the tension in NATO.
The tension I described earlier.
And I'm wondering if we have a US policy that
on the one hand either tries to control those
sales more tightly as some have subscribed
to the...excuse me.
Ascribed to the previous administration or
a policy that tries to promote American arms
sales abroad more vociferously particularly
if you use an anti-allied argument, "If they
don't sell it, we will.
If we don't sell it, they will."
in the process.
I wonder if in this respect we don't run the
risk of cutting down or shortchanging the
safety valve aspects of things and in fact
perhaps endangering the larger NATO allied
market which is where the real money if you
will often comes into play.
John Charles Daly: Senator Biden?
Senator Biden: I think you're absolutely correct.
You pose the problem very...in a very articulate
manner.
I think we get back to the fundamental question.
What is our foreign policy and what should
NATO be, how should it be made up and how
effective is it.
And part of the question of whether or not
it's effective relates to the interoperability,
the standardization.
Standardization is not merely motivated.
It is not primarily motivated by the requirement
of the French to get in on the deal.
It's motivated by the question that generals
know better than senators and that is how
do you have a unified battle plan without
having radios that can receive one another's
messages without having spare parts that can
be interchanged without having tanks and planes
and guns, etc., that are...can be used under
a unified command somewhat like a unified
army.
And that is the motivating factor.
Now once we reach that decision I think the
allies have a right to say, "Hey, wait a minute.
Now you ain't getting it all.
We want a piece of that."
And I think that we have to be willing to
make that decision.
There is a great deal of pressure from our
domestic arms manufacturers to say no, that
we don't want you "giving away any of our
piece of the market".
I think just as we've done in many other areas
of foreign relations we have to have the courage
and the...or the foresight to say we're going
to figure out what component, what portion
you're going to make up, United States, what
we're willing...what piece we're willing to
take.
Absent that, there is a great risk being run
in cutting off the safety valve.
You are absolutely correct because that's
part of the plan.
I believe because we haven't been willing
to follow through on what is clearly in our
strategic and conventional interest to do,
that is standardize, and the reason we haven't
been able to do it is in large part was because
of the economic decisions involved in it.
Because of that we have propelled to a greater
degree our allies in the markets that compete
with us in the Third World and many instances
force us to make decisions that are marginally
less detrimental than if we didn't move into
the area.
I think you state it very well.
John Charles Daly: General Scowcroft?
General Scowcroft: I agree with the Senator.
I think what we need to work on is the NATO
part rather than the safety valve part because...
Senator Biden: I agree.
General Scowcroft: You know, NATO spends more
than the Warsaw Pact does on arms and yet,
you know, we're woefully behind in preparedness.
One of the reasons is that each country goes
out and builds its own little system.
They don't work together, they're not standardized
and so on.
We're one of the biggest culprits.
Not only for economic reason but military.
Our own military tend to think that unless
it's our equipment it's not good enough and
we have worldwide concerns not just in NATO
and therefore we have to have our own unique
equipment.
I think we need to do far more.
And we need to take the lead.
John Charles Daly: Representative Dickinson?
Representative Dickinson: I don't disagree
with what has been said.
I thought maybe I would...it would perhaps
be helpful to put it in a little different
context.
For the past few years I've been a delegate
to the North Atlantic Alliance or Assembly
and this is...the question comes up.
There is an economic section, a political
section and a military section and I'm on
the military section.
And this question comes up every time we meet.
Well, if we met six times a year that's how
many times it would come up.
It's a two-way street, RSI.
And one of the things that causes the breakdown
is that our NATO allies say, "Well, look.
We're buying more weapons from you than you're
buying from us and so it's not fair."
And the American reply is, "Well, look.
You're not counting the cost of us stationing
our troops in Europe and if you put in the
cost of what we're spending to station our
troops in Europe to defend you we're spending
more than you're spending."
So it's a...it goes round and round.
But I think in the final analysis of your
major systems that I think the answer is going
to have to be what we did with the F16.
That is you're gonna break down and everybody
that wants to get in on the act, all the counties,
they make components and General Dynamics
is making a part here and the Belgians are
making a part there and this seems to be working
pretty well and rather than saying, "Well,
you...we'll build this airplane and you build
that tank and we'll swap out."
So I think that now the road we're gonna find
is probably the most practical way to build.
John Charles Daly: All right.
Next question please.
Major Hudson: I'm Major Bill Hudson.
I'm a US Air Force Research Associate at Vance
International Studies Institute.
Congressman Aspin indicated earlier he felt
that arms sales or arms transfers actually
had perhaps very little leverage.
This seems to be the substance of what the
panel discussion is about.
I wonder if you could all reply concretely
to the fact or to the opinion, do you think
that arms transfers compare favorable to other
foreign policy tools, diplomatic or economic
in achieving concrete results such as basing
rights or more generally leverage our influence.
John Charles Daly: You wanna start, congressman?
Representative Aspin: I think that what I
meant was that I think leverage is very often
overstated and it's easy to anticipate a lot
of leverage when in fact the leverage may
not be very great.
And I can think of some examples.
One of the arguments is that arms sales give
us some control over the use of those...of
that weapons because if you keep control over
the ammunition and the spare parts you're
then gonna have some...the country a little
bit on a leash as to whether the stuff gets
used or not.
But there are military engagements in which
you don't use up a lot of ammunition and spare
parts.
Israel bombed the Iraqi reactor.
One swift blow and you may have all the control
over ammunition and spare parts and it doesn't
give you much leverage.
Also countries have a way of building up enough
consumables.
I think the shah of Iran set up a particular
policy of trying to actually build up enough
consumables of ammunition and spare parts
for the very purpose of shaking loose and
getting a little bit more flexibility.
I mean, in the old days back in the '50s we
seemed to have a lot of leverage but back
in the '50s there was more than arms sales.
We were also giving economic grants and all
kinds of other economic aid and the Russians
were nowhere near as omnipresent as they are
now.
And so we had a great deal of influence but
I think people look back on that and think
that the arms sales gave us leverage when
in fact it was a whole constellation of aid
and assistance and underwriting them financially
which gave us the leverage.
Leverage is a point but I think it's very
often overstated in the arguments when it
comes down to a particular arms sale.
John Charles Daly: Anybody wanna add anything to that?
Senator Biden: Slightly more than Food Through
Peace, slightly less than technology.
General Scowcroft: I think the question...the
issue is more complicated than influence.
If by influence you mean we're buying influence
by selling arms and that therefore they'll
do what we want, I think the answer is clearly
no but it's a much more subtle kind of an
influence.
Theoretically it helps these people with their
own purposes.
It gives them a certain amount of self-confidence.
In some cases, it's vital to preserving the
military balance.
You take countries like Korea for example.
Were we to shut Korea off, you know, the results
could clearly be disaster.
North Korea gives every indication that if
they thought they could succeed they would
attack.
Turkey is another case where a clear military
necessity, others are political.
But I think you can't just look at cause and
effect.
I think it's much more subtle and as Congressman
Aspin said earlier in many cases the influence
is purely negative and that is if you don't
do it you really disrupt your foreign policy.
Representative Dickinson: Let me give one
small example of what the general's saying.
I think in the School of the Americas which
is run in Panama to train military officers
from Latin American countries and in this
country our National War College, Air War
College, all the services have them, we bring in
foreign students and they're the cream of
the crop from that country.
And the cultural exchange and the one on one
relationship that are developed then have
very long lasting...because there are the
people who will ultimately be in the leadership
of those countries.
And so that's a dividend that you can't overlook
that most people really seem to be unaware
of.
John Charles Daly: Well, I very much regret but
our time has run out and this concludes another
public policy forum presented by the American
Enterprise Institute for Public Policy Research.
On behalf of AEI our hearty thanks to the
expert panelists, General Brent Scowcroft,
Representative William L. Dickinson, Senator
Joseph R. Biden Junior and Representative
Les Aspin and our thanks also to our guests
and experts in the audience for their participation.
Goodbye from Washington.
Announcer: It is the aim of AEI to clarify issues
of the day by presenting many viewpoints in
the hope that by doing so those who wish to
learn about the decision making process will
benefit from such a free exchange of informed
and enlightened opinion.
This public policy forum series is created
and supplied to this station as a public service
by the American Enterprise Institute, Washington,
DC.
AEI is a nonprofit, nonpartisan publically
supported research and education organization.
Information on this and other subject areas
including government regulation, economic
policy, social security and retirement, health
policy, legal policy, tax policy, political
and social processes, energy policy, defense
policy and international affairs is available
from the institute.
For a transcript of this program send $3.75
to the American Enterprise Institute, 1150
17th Street Northwest, Washington, DC 20036.